to distill it down to its its little in
a nutshell Aaron roders
insinuated that Jimmy Kimmel is on
Jeffrey Epstein's list and as such is
some kind of a predator of children and
um Jimmy Kimmel was none too pleased
about that fired off on Aaron Rodgers
like devoted his entire opening
monologue on the Kimmel show to just
destroying Aaron roders and Aaron roders
since is no longer welcome on the pat
mcae show well only a certain not the
whole list came out right it was just
the list came out but but uh Aaron
Rogers responded and he's like let me
clarify yeah Aaron Rogers responded
basically saying let me not apologize
whatsoever and like try to like get some
digs in and like I mean it's just a big
catastrophic L from the way I see it so
our question at the moment is who took
the bigger L who's the bigger loser of
the week Aaron Rogers or Cat Williams
but why would you even think that Cat
Williams took an L well I mean this is
the what did he do what did he do that
you didn't like I mean hey he didn't do
anything I didn't like I'm just seeing
that he attacked everybody Under the Sun
it seems like he set about trying to
burn every bridge he possibly could I
mean dude I just went through a list but
he said he's like I have the receipts
and everybody the receipts for saying
that Harvey Weinstein offered to S his s
his
D in front of a bunch of people like he
said a lot of things that actually there
are no receipts for well nobody has
refuted anything that he had to
say so like people did respond to to to
cat but they never denied what he was
saying uh Tiffany hartish uh
categorically
denied uh she she refuted everything
that he said about her well didn't he
say that like the the the people that
are involved with the Inner Circle their
only job is to refute everything that is
claimed against them towards like the
Illuminati you didn't hear him say that
so now we've got receipts for the
Illuminati huh well I mean that's what
he's saying you know but nobody has said
anything
different I mean here's the thing um I
think that he uh slung a lot of mud he
he Tred to burn a lot of bridges and um
he definitely got a lot of news I mean
we like the the most uh compelling thing
we could think of to start the podcast
is is story about him like uh you know
so you'd think that it was a huge W but
why do you think he goes on this huge
platform and just starts and just starts
bashing everybody do you think there's a
little bitterness between like everybody
lit a lot of bitterness for sure yeah
yeah for sure 100% there's bitterness
with uh Kevin Hart and Tiffany hadish I
forget what the origin of that was but
uh now as far as career goes do you
think Tiffany hadish is more successful
than Cat Williams that's I don't know
man cat here's the thing dude Tiffany
haish went from like not a a like big
celebrity to a Bonafide like A-list
movie star and then she got tangled up
in in some kind of accusations and like
some kind of a lawsuit situation with
who Aries Spears was it and uh that
really really hurt her and then since
had a bunch M really not a bunch she got
two but but still like when you get a
second DUI like it's so I think that I I
love Tiffany hadish I love her but I
think that like objectively like from a
career standpoint she like you know was
she had a quicker come up well no she
she's been doing standup since she was
like a teager yeah and then she came up
like you know whatever like a few years
ago it's like uh more than a few years
ago but um
but yeah she she came up a little like
after many many years of doing standup
came up humongously yeah meteoric [__]
straight to the boom like like you know
well so what do you think's gonna happen
to cat after this I mean he's going to
be doing larger shows because his
popularity grew and Rogan just invited
him to go on right I mean I mean he's he
just blew himself up and this is a new
podcast and I think he got like 2
million views 2 million subscribers
overnight oh my god dude that episode 41
million views in seven days how much
money is that on AdSense okay so that's
literally just the the Cat Williams
episode has 41 million views in seven
days Jesus wow what's the what's the
AdSense revenue on that at like $5 for
thousand if he's got mid rolls built in
uh I
mean it's every million views he's
getting
$5,000 I think it's probably more like
every million views you get a thousand
oh that's a dollar Still Still Still
that's uh that's 40,000 but if he's got
mid rolls then he's in the six
figures I I read something this morning
that he he got a quarter of a million
dollars just off of AdSense for this I
wouldn't be surprised I wouldn't be
surprised and and and I say that because
he's um you know like like ads is based
on how ad friendly you are that's why uh
like my main YouTube channel is very low
on the cpms which is the how much you
get per thousand views like I'm uh edgy
and Roman Atwoods is through the roof
because he's kidfriendly right right
it's family friendly so I think that uh
so you think he took an L I mean I don't
okay maybe you know what maybe I'm
converted maybe you're right especially
because with all of Cat Williams history
of just being
arrested like time and time again like
violence I think he had like guns like
crazy one thing after another he was
just like constantly in trouble and
doing very well in his career despite
that fact so do you think him doing
something like this gets him blackballed
from doing like major Motion Pictures he
he said he was been in 60 movies
according to IMDb it checks out um I
mean he pays people out of his own
pocket he's adopted seven kids I mean
there's adopted seven kids yeah he's got
seven kids adopted I mean the the amount
of stories that came out on him on like
yeah dude like I was struggling and like
dude somebody came up and handed me like
a t-shirt wrapped up and he's like a
front row at at his seat and there was
like a struggling comedian and he's like
Oh I thought it was just a bunch of weed
and he's like it came back it was 15
grand Richie reading has nothing but
good things to say about him yeah I mean
the he said he bought a a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame put 75 grand in
for some some singer that uh you know
he's like during that time like she got
hated on because of the color of her
skin he's like he bought her the star I
mean I mean he's a Bonafide lunatic I
think his what cat so I don't think he
necessarily cares and to answer your
question did he get black balled he's
been black balled right L and that's why
he's lashing out like that well he he
he's been blackballed because they said
he was difficult to work with but then
his his reasoning was like well I'm just
not going to you know yeah wear a
[__] dress there was a point before
uh Suge Knight went to prison Suge
Knight was like all of a sudden acting
as his manager some weird thing really
yeah put shg Knight and Cat Williams Su
Knight has a podcast that he does from
jail from a pay phone no he does
not yeah it's called Uh yeah look that
up uh if that's true that's Epic Cat
Williams said his arrest alongside sug
Knight in
2014 wasn't what it
appeared
yeah hey look up uh sug Knight's
podcast that is just really really
funny um collect calls calls with SH
night how many how many subscribers does
it
have collect 600 break beat me media I
me that's pretty epic he's probably got
some [__] to say
wow wow such a good name too that's a
really good prison
podcast um you made a lot of collect
calls from prison uh I mean I was never
in prison I was in county jail and uh I
I made some calls Who you calling in
prison in jail whoever you know like I
like I was in jail for my dad's birthday
in uh 1996 and I never had ever forgot
my dad's birthday is the one time I
didn't call my dad on his birthday
because I didn't have the heart for him
to pick up the phone and and hear you're
receiving a call from inal facility so I
just acted as if I forgot his birthday
that year
yeah would you did you ever tell him
that like that's the reason yeah I I I
died many many years later many many
years later uh yeah he didn't know I was
in jail um but in any case so uh to
answer your question no I don't think
that Cat Williams
career suffers because of this because
like you know any um issues that it
would cause have already been caused is
my guess yeah um it does benefit I me
now he goes on
Rogan like uh Kevin Hart took the high
road saying I hope his career kills it
and this that you know and like it's
it's a case where negative publicity is
actually good publicity
he went after Steve Harvey oh my God he
went after everybody Steve Harvey Cedric
the
Entertainer uh ludicrous like Tiffany
hadish Kevin Hart ludicrous um teraji oh
maybe didn't go after her maybe
supportive I don't know it was insane do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude